I'm gonna back up a little bit Blake
finally tells you he wants to be with
you was that a surprise for you and why
did you ultimately end things yeah so
Blake coming to me to tell me that he
was having feelings for me was a
complete surprise just because at that
point I shut my feelings down so far and
I thought he did CEO because I honestly
encouraged him I said listen what are
you doing in paradise I said I want
Hannah I said you should pursue her and
that's what she did yeah so what so why
couldn't you get those feelings back too
little too late or what was it I think
it was a lot of everything that's
happened and you keep wanting to go to
paradise early on in a friendship and I
was like I don't want somebody who wants
to go to paradise obviously they don't
choose me and then I found out about his
night with someone else like three days
before and I was like okay I wouldn't
want that was someone treating me that
way everything else just escalated
quickly in paradise and I just shut down
and shut down shut down and then did it
feel like a little bit of good
vindication I wouldn't say that
like what you wondered I mean you know
it's this guy who kind of wasn't totally
honest with you and you had come into
paradise saying look I want to make
Blake cry a little bit okay that was a
complete joke because I remember talking
to one of the producers and I was like
hey look I want to have fun I want to be
like funny people see that side of me
because I do have like this sense of
humor and it's been a different side of
you I mean we saw you crying a lot more
on your last round of paradise but there
has been some backlash towards you how
have you felt about that and what would
you say to those people I did receive a
lot of backlash and unfortunately like
we all real people and the fact that
Lake is getting it I think I got the
kind of leftovers of that hate for
choosing to keep him around because my
choice to keep him around was to look he
deserves to find love and I see the
genuine and him not to like make him a
better
well now I let myself be over again so
today I'm going to make blades my fish
that was a joke and I told like I was
like hey Mike welcome to your personal
hell
but he knew everything that I was
telling him it's not like surprise
people also gave you a little backlash
for things with Caitlyn saying that you
were staying in Paradise for a
friendship rose what do you say to them
I can do whatever I want with their hoes
I mean like yeah and ship rose and they
both knew way before Kalyn sat down and
at me what was unfortunate about that
situation he said she kept going after
me like hey what are your intentions and
I'm like my intention that she goes what
are you doing here now it became
frustrating for me what do you say to
people who have been coming after Blake
you've defended him a little bit on
social media are you still defending him
I'm supporting him because I think he
needs an he's had so many people on that
beach be supportive of him and be there
his friend but when the show started
airing he didn't see a majority of those
people so he feels I mean a form of
betrayal and that nobody was there for
him so I just continue someone to hold
his hand and show that hey I've been
here for you for a year
was he in a dark place I
from my perspective I say I haven't seen
him in this position ever before and it
was hard to watch but I think it's his
his position to say how he where he was
how did you feel about his performance
during the finale for example he did not
want to apologize for releasing the text
messages between him and Kalyn and a lot
of people in the cast were saying dude
just say sorry I know a lot of people
were saying say sorry but I think for
Blake he had to feel at where I was
coming from to apply to apologize for
the text messages that just doesn't seem
right because I think there's more to it
there's an apology look do you think he
should have released them no then it's a
lot of gray area in that subject just
because I again I can only speak it on
myself if I were in his shoes and
somebody told the whole nation millions
of viewers that I silenced somebody
knowing that there's a sexual assault
victim I would find a way to be like
that's not true
but he had a couple of Ally points
sitting in an interview how can he trust
her to say what it is when she lied to
there
how do you feel like you handled tonight
though because I have to be honest
watching it I don't think Blake got a
ton of Redemption you know people didn't
walk away saying okay we forgive you and
hands weren't shook it was kind of the
opposite no I completely agree with you
I think he started off strong and he had
the confidence until other people
started by chiming in and still having
an opinion on it and I think again wants
he crumbled I just think I think Blake
just needs a logo of his ego recognized
when things are wrong apologize for them
on your actions and honor like should be
easier I gotta ask you about a different
stagecoach moment you and Kailyn brought
up another man who was involved with the
two of you who are you talking about I I
did okay I just the point of me bringing
up this guy is because I gave Kayla and
benefit of them and she personally did
something and I'd like maybe a country
singer you flew in with him was he a
singer a member of bachelor nation nope
nope nope a country singer then nope oh
yeah I don't want to mention her it is
just because it's I guess not relevant I
just wanted to say what my situation was
with Kailyn and it wasn't that I just
disregarded her from the get-go it's it
was a little bit more first one she did
it personally it sounds like you guys
have a lot of history last question for
you how will you and Kailyn walk away
from tonight are you friendly are you
not where are things that I just I've
told Cohen from the moment sorry I keep
hitting the mic that I'm indifferent
about her I just didn't trust her
intentions when she was on coding season
and I just I was indifferent I'll see
her in the van I'll say hello I'm not
like oh you're a mean girl like I don't
wanna talk to you none of that I just
it's just another person that I know
[Music]
[Applause]